what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with well not really back uh
we're doing moon night the story where
he fights deadpool now this is also
important because
strange enough it's the first time moon
knight meets deadpool which is one of
the downsides to vengeance of moon
knight the story itself was great right
the first six issues were great and i
pretty much loved the whole run but
there were some things that just kind of
stretched the limits of credulity like
this is really the first time that moon
knight has ever met deadpool or the two
of them have ever heard of each other
especially considering the fact that
moon knight was a member of the avengers
at one point in time but hey you just
gotta roll with it but what is up
happening here is mark spector basically
gets word that there's a kind of
disturbance at mount sinai hospital and
when he gets there he finds a piece of
pizza now as he's making his way through
this place
[Laughter]
everybody is absolutely terrified right
and they're like it was it was
absolutely crazy it was this crazy guy
none of the patients are touched which
is really kind of weird to him because
his thought is if somebody's going to
break into a hospital you'd probably go
after the patients but when he ends up
smashing into a room which where the
door was basically still moving
indicating the person has just gotten
there he's met by deadpool
now right off the bat moon knight
attacks deadpool now the reason for this
is because at this point in time in moon
knight's story this is part of what was
called the heroic age and the heroic age
was kind of like the the aftermath or
sort of the new era during this 10-year
run or 10-year rework of marvel comics
at the hands of editor-in-chief joe
quesada that what you had really going
from i mean it's kind of hard to spot an
exact time frame but you could really go
with like avengers disassembled and
spider-man one more day running all the
way up like through the entire 2000s
right so running all the way up to 2009
2010 with the conclusion of dark rain
which was basically a wholesale
reworking of the superhero community and
since the superheroes had become too
dark they become too gritty and the goal
was to basically take them back to their
roots as being superheroes now fat lot
of good it did literally within two
years cyclops of the x-men killed
professor x in the avengers versus x-men
storyline so they didn't really return
to classic superhero themes uh some of
them did some of them didn't but for for
moon knight this is a kind of an era in
his character's history where he doesn't
kill so that's kind of the batman
parallel right batman doesn't kill
munite doesn't kill which by all
standards just because a hero doesn't
kill does not mean they're batman it's
everything else about moon knight that
basically makes him batman in addition
to this so that's kind of the thing that
that really kicks off here so of course
a fight breaks out between himself and
deadpool because as far as he's
concerned deadpool's just killing a coma
patient in a hospital he doesn't really
know the full story here now one of the
things that really really split the
comic book community when this story
came out is whether or not moon knight
could actually defeat deadpool he
actually does like he overcomes deadpool
like he's able to basically thwart him
now it's not a full-on knock-down dragon
fight i mean it is to a degree but it's
one of those things where like moon
knight gets the upper hand and then like
a super hot nurse comes out of like the
elevator wearing virtually nothing with
like some beers and some pizza which as
we know with deadpool is always a
fantastic thing
but ultimately moon knight takes that
kind of distraction to get the upper
hand and then throws throws deadpool out
of window and when he looks down of
course deadpool's basically gone but
that was kind of the question is could
deadpool or could could moonlight
actually defeat deadpool now what you'll
see over the course of this is that it's
actually handled really really well and
it is believable that mark spectre could
defeat deadpool but what is going on is
that moon knight basically takes a step
back and starts looking at everything
that's going on analyzing this and
realizing that the guy he saved and the
person that deadpool was going to kill
was somebody named hermann goncharenko
and the whole idea behind this is that
this was a guy who came from the ukraine
and was basically running guns and all
kinds of stuff throughout the us he
essentially created a kind of mob life
for himself not only that the idea here
is that while he loved everything going
on in the states that he started getting
himself involved in legitimate
businesses which in effect basically
means money laundering but the other
part of this is that in order to make
room for like his developments the
things he wanted to build right in order
to expand his own wealth on a on a
legitimate level he would basically
force people out of their homes now
almost everybody who was confronted by
his men basically left because they knew
that like they would end up getting
killed if they didn't but there were
some who refused to leave right who
basically play uh played it brave and
the way that would play out is suddenly
they would go missing people would just
disappear bodies would show up somewhere
right so very much kind of keeping him
and his men off the books insofar as
having any direct involvement with
regards to what's going on but they were
basically killing people who refused to
move out of their homes in an effort to
like remove them from the equation as
well as instill fear across everybody
else right make an example out of person
a and if person b is scared enough
they'll do whatever you tell them to and
so that was really what he was going
with here the problem is that as with
most cases in this and it's one of those
things that moon knight kind of hits on
he's like that's the problem with due
process and that's the beauty of america
innocent until proven guilty that while
you may know that they're guilty it's
like that line from law abiding citizen
it's not what you know it's what you can
prove in court that's what matters the
most so even if everybody knows that
this person committed this crime that's
not enough you have to provide evidence
to link them to the crime and so long as
that evidence isn't there there's
nothing that can be done that's
literally how they got al capone on tax
evasion they couldn't get him for
anything else
the guy was squeaky clean which by the
way uh if you guys ever saw boardwalk
empire that show's amazing but unless so
so back into this what we end up finding
out is that the person who hired
deadpool is actually one of the victims
of herman himself that this woman her
family was basically killed her husband
and her daughter were killed by this guy
in an effort to like get them to leave
their home and while it seemed to work
what ended up happening is of course she
swore out of vendetta now one of the
funny things about this is that uh when
he shows up and he's basically talking
to her she asked the question is he dead
the response to deadpool is no like he's
not dead uh basically a guy with a hood
and a cape kind of thing throwing stars
shaped like moons but do you think
anybody ever gets hit with like the
smooth part of that no it's always the
pointy part it's deadpool going on his
little tangents
this is random little things and that's
what's kind of funny is because of
course that's when the woman kind of
gives her backstory you know we
basically learned what had gone on that
is very much like a personal thing not
only that she wants him killed she
doesn't want him dead now there is a
distinction here the distinction being
that this guy's basically dying already
but it's not enough that he'd die of
natural causes because in her mind and i
could see the justification in this she
sees it as though he kind of got away
with it all what she wants is for him to
be killed so he knows someone figured
him out like someone has basically found
a way to get rid of him right someone
finally got their revenge she finally
got her revenge now when when deadpool
and moon knight end up meeting up a
second time this is when things are
intriguing because when deadpool's kinda
like okay so how did you find me the
response of moon night is somebody hired
you somebody hired you to do this job
they hired you to take this guy out uh
and at the end of the day i totally get
what you're essentially coming from but
i can't support this right i cannot
support you going out and just killing a
guy because of some stuff that he did
that at the end of the day due process
has to reign supreme now the funny thing
here is deadpool's response is like get
out of this while you can moon night
like your heart's not in this somebody
tells me that maybe you get what it is
that i'm doing and you've even done the
pay for slay yourself and so he asked
like what happened to you right like
that you're here now wasting my time
with the school harm routine right your
knees a little wobbly and beneath that
kind of stuff you know it's one of those
things where deadpool kind of taunts him
a little bit now here's the thing to
understand that while this is moon night
by and large this is the jake lockley
persona that's basically operating here
that's one of the things to remember is
that uh that moon knight has three
different identities right you've
basically got like the moon knight
character but beyond that you have mark
spector who is the i guess identity
number one the original person who
eventually became moon knight when he
was left for dead by raul bushman and
left below the statue of uh konchu and
then ultimately agreed to become
conscious agent on earth in order to
have his life restored and then there is
jake lockley and their steve grant that
the whole idea of moonaid having
disassociative identity disorder is that
he created the identity of jake lockley
in order to operate on the ground level
keep his ear to the ground talk to
people who were basically vagrants and
gain information and so on and steve
grant is his quote unquote bruce wayne
persona but ultimately he got lost in
those and so he doesn't know which one
is which and there's even been different
stories where they teased the idea that
the creation of jake lockley and the
creation of steve grant weren't
necessarily done for the purpose of
helping moon knight achieve his goal to
rid the world of crime but is actually
rooted in his ability to cope with the
circumstances that he's in that they're
essentially identities of escape and
that in an attempt to escape he got lost
in those identities so it depends on on
you know what era of stories you're
reading right who it is that you're
talking to but in the midst of this
conflict with deadpool he's basically
informed that there's an abandoned
building in hell's kitchen that's owned
by one of hermann's shell corporations
and that's the best place to start
because if his shell corporation owns it
nothing links it directly to him and so
if it's something where like some kind
of act goes down or for whatever reason
cops end up invading the premises that
in effect herman has no involvement he's
like i have no idea what's going on
there right this company owned it and
that's as far as they can go with it
they can't actually trace it back to him
at least not legally anyway i mean i'm
sure they could use all kinds of illegal
tactics to actually trace it back to
hermann but legally they can't
necessarily go that way what we also end
up finding out is that there was a
recent incident where a kid went missing
and that presumably herman was behind it
which is one what brings deadpool in but
two what also keeps moon knight on the
trail trying to find a way to bring this
guy down now of course the kid is very
much alive but the henchmen ultimately
decide to make the move of taking the
kid out just because of the fact that
they don't think their boss is going to
return so it's just like get rid of this
kid so that we don't have any loose ends
right and then whatever happens happen
now of course as you would expect uh
moon knight lets the kid die
that's not true i don't know why i told
you guys that of course he steps in
of course moon knight steps in and
basically saves this kid's life and
essentially beats the crap out of these
guys right absolutely torments these
guys and then ultimately ends up
liberating the kid basically freeing the
kid getting him out of there and getting
him back to safety at that point it's
okay what do we find the rest of these
guys right like how do we get the rest
of this stuff sorted out basically
interrogating the the henchmen of
hermann and so on and so forth he
ultimately ends up at mr flappy's
funhouse
which i gotta admit is kind of a
hilarious name for a uh for a little bit
of a carnival or i guess a fair whatever
you want to call it right so i'm just
kind of theme park of sorts uh but
ultimately again a fight breaks out
between the two now unlike the previous
fight that we saw this is the actual
fight between the two right this is a
knock down drag out no holds barred
fight now one of the things to also know
is that konchu over the course of the
vengeance of moon knight has always kind
of been lingering in the background that
moon knight's always been trying to
basically ignore the influence of konshu
but the more he ignores it the more i
guess the larger kanchu becomes the more
impactful he becomes it's one of those
things where it kind of runs in parallel
with the concern moot knight has of that
you know deadpool making the statement
your heart's not in this him kind of
asking the question how long can i
maintain this no killing rule and when
will i eventually fall back into killing
bad guys i mean more recently we know
that he fell back into it pretty fast i
mean literally this run only lasted 10
issues and then it was relaunched as
moon knight vol 3. but the thing about
this is that uh that khan just kind of
lingers in the background there which is
why you see him and you see him kind of
trying to subtly influence moon knight
get him to kill that kind of stuff the
fact remains that in terms of fighting
between these two and this is where
things get highly debatable so i
wouldn't be surprised if the comment
section goes kind of nuts with people
going back and forth over who would
actually win in this particular battle
uh that the way the the community more
or less justify this or kind of split it
is that while deadpool is exceedingly
brutal moon knight's faster right moon
knight's faster and i wouldn't
necessarily say more capable but if
you're talking about two guys who are
relatively equal in terms of their
capabilities i would argue that the
faster one is probably the one who would
win but deadpool has a healing factor
which really kind of adds to the
complication of things because he can
instantaneously heal from virtually
anything any kind of pain that he
endures i mean i guess it's not
necessarily instantaneous but it might
as well be given how like extreme his
healing factor is and so with with mark
spector realizing that what this does is
it actually allows a kind of release
right with all the things that he's been
facing off against since the beginning
beginning of his no killing rule he
comes to the realization that with
deadpool basically having a healing
factor the guy's a punching bag he can
attack him as much as he wants to he can
tear him up as much as he wants to and
deadpool can handle it deadpool can take
it so quite literally this is not a
traditional moon knight facing off
against deadpool it's an enraged version
of his character filled with just like
just anger and wrath and all that kind
of stuff and literally deadpool is the
source of all of that so every ounce of
capability for moon knight comes to bear
against deadpool and that's why a lot of
people say given you know given the the
right kind of context moon knight could
legitimately defeat deadpool but again
it is a debatable thing because i
imagine a lot of people who are really
knowledgeable on deadpool myself
included would kind of question that and
be like i mean moonlight's good man but
i don't know if he could actually defeat
deadpool right deadpool is a master
assassin i mean this guy has taken on
and defeated people well beyond the
likes of moon knight so it's not as
though moon is just fighting a random
dude out there i mean deadpool is a
match for wolverine and i imagine
wolverine could easily take on moon
knight so i'm not a hundred percent sure
how exactly this would unfold but i lean
more towards the idea that deadpool
would be the one to come out on top and
so ultimately what ends up happening is
that uh deadpool is visited by the woman
who hired it right and when she when the
two of them kind of have a conversation
you know deadpool sort of hobbles his
way up there
and she asks like is he dead he's like
remember that guy with the cape that i
told you about and she's like okay so
like that guy defeated you again and and
her question is kind of like so
basically this guy herman just gets to
continue breathing he gets to just kind
of continue doing his thing being tended
to by nurses and all that kind of stuff
and you're being defeated by a guy in a
white suit with like some some moon
shaped throwing stars basically and so
it was one of those things where she's
like okay look if you can't do this then
i will do it myself and so what ends up
happening here is that moon knight
almost seems to give up now there is
some ambiguity here right the various
faces of the victims of of uh hermann
are really just kind of haunting moon
knight here right like the people who
have you know herman himself sort of
taunting him like i got away with all
these crimes right the kid that he
rescued the people who have died it
really haunts him and what he seemingly
does is just cast aside this no killing
rule he takes off basically with the
intention of killing herman himself the
problem is that when he gets there right
this woman is basically shown up and
she's masquerading as a nurse and when
she's told we need you to basically tend
to the patient in room 309 right to
basically ensure this guy gets his
injections like he's supposed to she
rolls in there and then she basically
ends up using potassium chloride now
here's the reason why she uses this
right what she's basically doing is
sentencing him to execution by way of
lethal injection the difference here is
that potassium chloride is only one part
of the lethal injection process the
second part or really i don't know i'm
not really taking this in order but like
the other two drugs that are used
there's pancuronium bromide which is
basically a neuromuscular blocking agent
right essentially paralyzes you and then
after that or at least as part of that
they give you a sodium thiopental uh
which is also i don't remember it's got
some kind of other name that they use
for it uh but that's one that's
basically an anesthetic but in essence
potassium chloride that's the one that
kills you it induces a heart attack and
so literally she's basically sentencing
this guy to execution by way of lethal
injection without any of the other drugs
that are used in order to ease the
process so she's basically giving this
dude a heart attack and making him
experience it and that's why she says
you killed my husband and my little girl
she had curly brown hair she loved
broccoli had a laugh straight from her
belly and my husband well he was the
best right i always felt safe whenever
he was near me this is why i'm glad
you're conscious i wouldn't want you to
miss a thing and she says this is going
to hurt a lot right i want my hatred to
be the last thing you see like she wants
them to experience like to live through
a heart attack not really live through
it but to feel the physical pain of a
heart attack and to just die right there
on the spot and she does kill him and
while that goes down moon knight just
kind of watches it right just watches it
all unfold and that's where the
ambiguity comes into play because we're
kind of left here to ask the question
would moon knight have actually killed
this guy right would you would he have
killed this guy himself and my answer is
yes because by watching this woman kill
this guy and then just doing nothing and
basically just kind of walking away then
at the end of the day moon knight
realized this guy just needed to die
right this guy just had to go he'd done
too many terrible things to too many
terrible people and the world was better
off without him but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end let me know what you guys think down
in the comment section thank you all for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace